[Applause]
look at those two
having the time of their life
[Applause]
the baby's playing together
[Music]
he just abandoned the stick
[Music]
look at how beautiful this sky looks
right now
look at this Sky whole lemon look at how
beautiful that is
so we decided to bring tiger to the park
it is four o'clock but right now in our
side of the U.S the sun has been setting
oh I just can't get over this
I'm sorry the sun has been setting super
early so by five o'clock it's completely
dark
um but we've been working so hard all
day
um and Tyga hasn't been in school right
now because
if you're not all caught up
um due to the seizures his medication's
been kind of acting up on and and the
side effects of the medication I should
say have caused him to get a little bit
overworked and super stressed and just
have a bunch of Behavioral issues at
school where we just decided to withdraw
him from that school and just see if
there's alternatives to his medication
so in the meantime he's not in school
um uh he he is on a curriculum and stuff
but
um playing is not one of those things
that he gets to do because we're all old
and we're working and stuff so Papa felt
really bad brought him to the park but I
have to show you this park I do want to
come back when it's a sunny day and show
you what it really looks like but this
is Fox Hills Park in Summerlin if you're
from Vegas
um and you don't know about this park
this park is superior okay before I show
you the park let me just show you CUNY
as Pablo
[Applause]
Jen and Papa get them Papa get them
she can't tap he can't tap Don't Tap
don't tap
[Applause]
ES
why do you do that
[Laughter]
banana
get him get him arm bar arm bar
turn away turn away no turn away turn
your body
okay so now Fox Hills tour okay you walk
it's literally in the middle of a bunch
of residentials and next to a school I'm
not sure if it's a high school or an
intermediate or middle school not sure
what it is but it's not so school as
soon as you walk here A bunch of Hills
this park has so much movement it's so
beautiful a bunch of open space see the
little Hills there's a hill there oh
this Sunset holy crap sorry
see a bunch of Hills everywhere
a ton of open space you can just let
your
kids and dogs and just [ __ ] ride your
little heart out and have them all run
okay and then here I don't know what the
hell this thing is called what is this
called help me but it is oh crap oh no
it's slushy mud [ __ ]
[ __ ] no
damn it oh no
okay well I'll clean those when I get
home but check this out
look at how cool this is this thing is
massive
like what [ __ ] look at this this is
epic
how beautiful is this and it goes all
the way around
look at this
okay how do I get out but yeah look at
this so damn rad it's like a roller a
net roller coaster
okay so from here you have this little
um
I don't know structure and that's where
the restrooms are in there but then you
have this guy
you sit on it
and it's all wobbly and [ __ ] okay and
then you have this guy holy crap this
guy's gorgeous sorry
nature just does some [ __ ] to me and I
[ __ ] love it it's
phenomenal okay look at that
you come over here and you have like a
little seesaw
teeter-totter seesaw again I love the
little Hills
that this park has
you sit in this
and then you spin this or are these kids
spin the [ __ ] out of your kids
and you have like a little music station
right here
and then a big ass Ball music station
you have these kids on like a Tire type
swing
and look at this structure let me get on
let me get in
I don't know where Dad and Taiko went
but yeah you have
this structure with more big balls
oh that's taika
and Papa
[Music]
how cute
look at that
this is just half of the park you guys
let's go catch up with Papa and tiger
okay so they left the zip tie and now
they're gonna go down the slide oh this
guy
okay look at these slides how rad are
these
so sick okay
go taika oh Jesus of course
gonna go together
hold on
ready yeah I'm ready
[Music]
I almost conquered my fear of heights
really
have you been on it no it's fast you go
you go with him no go just go with him
go just leave it take it
all right this lady talking all her
smack
yeah it's a children's playground
but
this thing is like
maybe even a three-story slide okay
I think two stories is where it says
please stay off those rocks that's
another story up there maybe two and a
half
story
but and look how tall this thing is
I bet she's gonna be scared I said no
breaks because the way you use brakes is
you stick your feet out on each side
like that so that you can Slow Down The
Descent and that's what most people do
but
I said no breaks
all right let's go mama
no breaks okay
[Applause]
is that fast or what that is faster I
think so oh [ __ ] I just cut my hair okay
oh no is that what you wanted are you
happy no sorry mama your turn
laughs
okay back on the tour but yeah
this out
this is the first floor that I was
initially showing you and there's more
stuff along that side
[Music]
okay
okay there goes taika again
go
you're ready
[Music]
of course he does he's so excited
yeah but I ended up cutting my finger on
a stupid rock
where is it
of course it's my middle finger
oh ready you ready yeah I go no no I
have to go faster you're gonna fall one
two no it's the same thing as before
that's all I'm doing just push your feet
go a little bit swell I will push your
feet yeah push your feet there you go
baby kitty
it's a fun toy
very dangerous yeah
yeah in the laundry machine ready
okay you could go as fast as possible
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
oh my world is upside down
are you okay
I can't believe you did it I would have
never done it
no no no we're gonna go
okay so we're back home I didn't get to
show you the rest of the park only
because Avi it got really really dark
um but we're back home to do taika's
gingerbread house are you pretty excited
monkey monkey
yes yes oh are you how can we look
surprised did I surprise you
what are you drinking
hot cocoa no it's apple cider Coca-Cola
okay so Trader Joe's has this apple
cider and
um it has very minimal ingredients so
it's not like super green I was kind of
hesitant to buy it just because I just
don't like anything with apple because
they add like so much sugar in it that
I'm like oh
but this bad boy is spiced cider apple
juice with other added ingredients okay
that was very specific
but it's unfiltered apple juice brewed
spice blends with cinnamon cloves out
all spice Orange Peel orange oil lemon
peel and that is it okay we're about to
start so I highly recommend you go to
Trader Joe's get this warm it up
put it over uh some heat warm it up and
then to be super cute if you want to be
super skinny I would suggest
you hang one of these boys on it
and it looks cute excuse me and it
tastes amazing so go get yourself that
okay you ready monkey monks
so the house I didn't even show you the
house I started decorating
but I know Tech is waiting so I'm gonna
have to show you later
but right now we are watching elf we
just finished dinner we just finished
our apple cider and now
mine oh okay fine that's fair
yeah that's fair okay so let's get the
party popping
I'm so excited okay so let's see what's
inside this kit
authentic German hexen house
with candy and cookie decorations
so we got some little pasteli M M's we
got something that's gonna make a huge
mess on our floor
yeah we got some gummy gums got some
cookies we got some tree yeah the
cookies we got some icing sugar oh my
God am I supposed to like
the snow
uh no this is the glue
it's not real glue it's icing and it's
gonna get hard so it's gonna make things
stick together but you can eat icing and
you can't eat glue that's why yeah okay
I don't know what part you got you'd out
about but okay
what's this
what is this
something very fragile
okay and then this is the house yeah
open it up but gentle
hold on hold on there might be though
there's something oh I think it's a
little kids ah careful oh yeah there are
that's an animal
a kid I saw a kid I saw kids clothes
kids and there should be a boy in here
somewhere I saw a boy
they're eating parts of the house that's
oh wait there's a what is this a lady a
lady a little Grammy grams with a little
King she's dumping out yeah you can eat
all of this
okay let's make the icing first so
because that's gonna be our glue
animal
animal people why they're not else
I have no idea we can ask the Germans
yeah we'll ask them
oh better not crying
[Music]